Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je plonge sur le récif, j’observe
les coraux, les petits poissons,
et tout à coup, une ombre massive
passe au-dessus de moi.
Je la vois.
C'est la première fois.
Elle est gigantesque
et tellement majestueuse.
Elle vole sur les récifs
comme un grand oiseau
qui planerait au-dessus d’une forêt.
À cet instant, le temps s’arrête.
J’en oublie même qu’il faudra remonter à
la surface pour reprendre ma respiration.
Elle passe, elle tourne,
puis elle revient vers moi
à chaque fois un peu plus près.
Toujours avec ce regard qui me fixe
et qui semble rempli de curiosité.
On s’observe l’un l’autre avec beaucoup
de questions, mais très peu de méfiance.
Et après quelques minutes qui ont semblé
une éternité, elle s’en va vers le large
et sa silhouette s’estompe
petit à petit dans le bleu.
C'était une raie manta.
Je suis remonté avec des images
dans la tête,
avec la sensation d’une expérience unique,
une interaction comme je n’en ai
jamais eue avec un animal sauvage,
qu’il soit marin ou terrestre.
Plein de questions me sont venues ;
je voulais en savoir plus sur cet animal,
apprendre à lire son comportement.
Les raies mantas, elles sont
connues de presque tous.
Elles sont représentées dans la culture
océanienne, dans les croyances,
ce sont des totems,
des dieux pour certains.
On les retrouve même
dans le fond de nos glacières.
(Rires)
Mais scientifiquement parlant,
je me suis aperçu qu’on ne sait
que très peu de choses de ces animaux.
C’est ce mystère qui a attisé
encore plus ma curiosité.
(Musique X-Files)
Que savons-nous des raies mantas ?
On sait qu’elles ont le plus gros
cerveau de tous les poissons
relativement à leur taille.
Ce sont des poissons surdoués.
Elles sont très intelligentes,
comme certains mammifères marins.
Ça se voit dans leur comportement.
Elles sont curieuses,
capables de socialiser, de jouer.
Des études ont montré qu’elles sont
capables de se reconnaître entre elles
et elles seraient conscientes
d’elles-mêmes.
Je comprends mieux ce regard curieux
qui me fixait lors de nos rencontres.
Mais ce qui m'impressionne le plus,
c'est leur taille.
Il existe deux espèces de raies mantas
dans le monde.
La plus grande peut mesurer
jusqu’à 8 mètres d’envergure.
Vous imaginez ?
C’est grand comme deux pianos
comme celui-ci.
Un nouveau-né mesure déjà
près de 1,30 m à la naissance.
Elles sont gigantesques.
Mais malgré cela, elles se nourrissent de
microparticules qu'on appelle le plancton.
C’est joli, non ?
Elles sont capables de descendre à plus
de 1000 m de profondeur pour se nourrir.
C'est plus profond que certaines espèces
de baleines ou d'orques, par exemple.
En plus de tout ça, vous n’avez
vraiment rien à craindre,
puisque, contrairement
à d’autres espèces de raies,
elles n’ont pas de dard ;
elles ont une queue, mais ne piquent pas,
elles sont complètement inoffensives.
Malheureusement, elles sont menacées.
Aux quatre coins du monde,
les raies mantas sont pêchées
et des populations entières sont décimées.
Leurs branchies sont
récoltées et utilisées
pour la médecine traditionnelle chinoise.
En savoir plus sur ces animaux n’est plus
simplement une question de curiosité,
mais plutôt une nécessité
pour mieux les protéger.
Il existe des méthodes pour connaître
un animal et sa population.
On pourrait utiliser la génétique
ou encore les balises satellites.
Dans les deux cas, ces études coûtent cher
et demandent un niveau d’expertise élevé.
Heureusement, il existe une méthode
bien plus facile, accessible à tous
et qui ne coûte presque rien.
C'est la science participative.
Ou comment un citoyen lambda peut
participer à des études scientifiques
et potentiellement répondre à des enjeux
cruciaux de conservation des espèces,
et notamment des espèces menacées.
Pour la raie manta,
comme pour d’autres animaux,
ce sont souvent de simples photos
qui sont utilisées -
c’est ce qu’on appelle
la photo-identification.
Le principe est simple : identifier des
marques uniques propres à chaque individu,
comme avec nos empreintes digitales.
Par exemple,
pour la tortue, on utilise la forme
et l’agencement des écailles.
Pour la baleine, c’est la forme
de la queue qui est unique.
Et pour le zèbre, vous l’aurez compris,
c’est un véritable code-barres vivant.
Et pour la raie manta, alors ?
Eh bien, il suffit de nager avec elle
et de tenter de capturer
une photo de leur ventre,
car c’est là que se trouvent les taches
uniques propres à chaque individu.
Et une fois ces tâches bien identifiées,
les photos sont stockées
dans une base de données
et comparées à d’autres photos d’archives.
Ça permet de les reconnaître
et d’accumuler les informations.
On peut comme ça les compter,
en savoir plus sur leurs mouvements, leur
comportement et même leur cycle de vie.
Regardez : ici, c’est Tani,
un mâle photographié à deux endroits
séparés de plus de 350 kilomètres.
D’autres exemples ont aussi permis
de montrer qu’elles peuvent
se déplacer sur de longues distances.
En Australie, une a été retrouvée
grâce à ses taches ventrales
à plus de 1000 kilomètres
de son site d'origine.
Même si elles parcourent
des centaines de kilomètres,
on a remarqué qu'elles ont plutôt
tendance à être sédentaires.
Ici, c’est Tamako,
un mâle qui a été photographié
pour la première fois en 1993.
Toujours grâce à ses taches,
on l’a retrouvé 26 ans plus tard,
en [2019], au même endroit,
et on continue de l’observer
régulièrement, toujours sur le même site.
Ici, c’est Helen,
une femelle, qui a été vue avec une
grosse morsure de requin en 2015.
A peine deux ans plus tard, en 2017,
ses blessures avaient
complètement disparu.
C'est un exemple qui montre le pouvoir
régénérateur des tissus de ces animaux.
Fascinant, non ?
C’est d’ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles on les chasse, mais à tort.
Et finalement, ici, c'est Big Mama.
Regardez son ventre.
On a suivi la grossesse de cette femelle,
permettant d’en savoir plus
sur la biologie de l’espèce.
Elles donnent naissance à un seul petit
après un an et un mois de gestation.
Toutes ces données permettent
d’établir des mesures de conservation
pour protéger ces espèces.
Par exemple, en savoir plus sur les
mouvements des raies mantas aux Maldives
a permis la création d’une aire marine
protégée et d’en déterminer la taille.
Mieux connaître leur comportement a permis
d’éditer un guide de bonnes pratiques
pour pouvoir les observer
sans les déranger.
Toutes ces informations sont générées
grâce à de nombreuses photos.
Je ne suis pas le seul à les prendre.
Pour que ce suivi fonctionne,
il faut vraiment un maximum de photos.
Plus il y en a, plus les résultats
seront précis et robustes.
C’est donc grâce
à de nombreux contributeurs
qui pensent à m’envoyer leurs observations
directement via les réseaux sociaux.
Et vraiment tout le monde peut participer.
Une simple photo ou vidéo,
même de mauvaise qualité,
on voit les taches sur le ventre,
avec en plus la date
et le lieu parce que c’est utile.
Et chaque observation compte.
Même une seule fois, même il y a longtemps
et même une raie manta qu’on a déjà vue.
En retour, chaque participant reçoit
des informations personnalisées
sur la raie manta qu’il a observée.
Et si certains sont sortis
de l’eau avec des questions,
la science participative permet
d’apporter des réponses.
La plus grande base de données du monde
compte plus de 70 000 photos
et des milliers de contributeurs.
Elle concerne la population de plus
de 5 000 raies mantas aux Maldives.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie, il existe
une base de données depuis 2016
et on compte déjà plus de 1 800 photos
et 180 contributeurs.
Grâce à ces photos, on a déjà identifié
plus de 400 raies mantas.
Si les raies mantas,
ce n’est pas votre truc,
(Rires)
que vous préférez les chauves-souris,
les serpents, les oiseaux, les escargots -
pourquoi pas ?
on n’est pas là pour juger -
(Rires)
avec la science participative,
il y en a vraiment pour tout le monde.
Il y a des chercheurs comme moi
qui ont besoin de données comme celles-ci.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie ou ailleurs,
il suffit juste de trouver
la plateforme qui convient.
Pour les raies mantas
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
c’est sur la page Facebook
de l’Initiative Manta.
Si, vous aussi, vous voulez
aider la science
et contribuer à la conservation
des espèces,
vous savez ce qu’il vous reste à faire :
à vos appareils photo !
Et je vous garantis que vous n’observerez
plus jamais la nature de la même façon.
(Applaudissements)